Elena  someone burned down your house with you  inside do you know anyone that would do  this  one day you wake up and your life is  settled and you know who you are  or at least you think you do this is MIA  everyone she's new to shake her yeah  do you even know anything about this  woman I saw her sleeping in her car you  rent it to a homeless person you know it  felt good helping I've been meaning to  hire someone for my house you should do  a little light cleaning some laundry you  mean to be your maid I meant more of a  house helper did I do the right thing  Rennie from the troupe a good mother  makes good choice he doesn't make good  choices who had good choices  have you really looked at yourself  the parts you're not afraid to look at  you  you